any agreement would of course need to
sign off from the 27 eu member states
let's find out if they are in
the mood to do a deal and we're joined
now from madrid by spain's
foreign minister aranja gonzalez
minister lovely to see you this morning
thank you so much for being on the
programme
um i wonder if we might begin by taking
your temperature and all of this
what chances of a trade deal between the
uk and the eu from your position
well i don't bet uh on trade deals
experience tells me that the final
stretch is always the most complicated
but what i would tell you is that from
the political point of view
for spain uh it's much better to end
with a deal
that to see the uk exit the european
union
without a deal and that's because we
think it's going to be better for both
of us
we are already suffering from a huge
impact of the pandemic and brexit would
just be
a double whammy and we want to avoid
that so
as far as spain is concerned we've told
the eu negotiator
to work for a deal and it's very clear
to us that he's working for a deal
do you detect the political will from
boris johnson and ursula van der laan to
get there though
well i know for a fact that uh ursula
van der lion has a very clear mandate
uh from the uh 27 european union member
states to look for a deal
to work for a deal like she's always had
as a mandate
like michelle barnier has always worked
to
towards but at the end of the day you
know it takes two to tango so at the end
of the day in order to reach a deal you
need to know that
both sides have been capable of
finding a landing strip for this plane
and get
to a deal but again no deal in the
current circumstances
would be extremely negative uh for our
economies
and if you go by what economists are
saying and there are there is plenty of
literature on that
the uk will suffer even more than the
european union we both will suffer
more on the uk side which i think is
something that we should
try to avoid at all costs obviously we
are in a negotiating process sites take
positions that
often get softened but let's look at the
the two key sticking points in all of
this
level playing field of course we'll move
on to in just a second but in terms of
the idea
that eu member states would be able to
fish in british waters
for a decade after the uk has left the
european union
you can understand i'm sure why that is
complete anathema to many people in the
united kingdom
well i just don't understand why uh we
cannot agree
uh to uh agree on fishing
fishing in the uk is six thousand
vessels
employing twelve thousand workers uh in
the uk that's
the size of the the magnitude of the
problem so i have difficulties uh
understanding why we cannot agree uh to
a landing zone on this
uh and i think it would be much better
for both of us uh
to reach a deal because on the other
side of the ledger
uh very pleased to say we've hit the
computer with a hammer we've sorted the
satellite and we're joined once again
from madrid
uh by spain's foreign minister aranja
gonzalez apologies
for the gremlins in the system this
morning minister um but let's return to
to where we were and we were discussing
fishing and you were you were answering
you were answering my question about
whether or not you understood why
so many people in the united kingdom
would not be pleased with a decade's
worth of access
to our territorial waters from what you
were saying
uh when you're suggesting that you know
you can't really understand why a deal
can't be
met on fishing that some of the
criticism was perhaps being pointed at
you know the negotiator on your side of
the table
look niall at the heart of this whether
it's on fishing or whether it's on level
playing field
is a very uh stark situation i've done
many trade agreements in my life
and trade agreements are not made to
assert one's
independence they are made to manage
our interdependence and this is what is
at stake here
of course there are european vessels
fishing in british waters
and there is british fish entering into
the european union
sometimes fresh fish sometimes processed
fished in the uk with higher value added
of course but the the question is not uh
stopping this it's managing this
interdependence
let's let's agree that this trade deal
that we are building
post brexit is not to assert people's
sovereignty country sovereignty
trade deals are not made to do that it's
pretty clear when you do a trade deal
that you're a sovereign nation
they are made to manage interdependence
the uk and the european union are
interdependent
so let's build a deal that reflects the
need
to manage this interdependence i i
understand and take the point but surely
this is a unique situation
in that we are moving away from the
european union
rather than wanting to be to be closer i
mean again surely you
understand why plenty of people who
voted to leave the european union in
this country
would not be happy for the united
kingdom to move forward being bound in
perpetuity
to standard set unilaterally by the
european union
no because this is not the point this is
not what the trade deal would do
it would not bind any of the parties to
perpetuity on terms
that are not desired and wanted by the
two parties
the question is here to build a
relationship
which is the one that two parties want
and desire because they understand their
interests the interest of their citizens
and the interests of their businesses
are better served through an agreement
that just simply
uh living without any terms
without any deal let me tell you niall
it
will have a stark consequences on our
economies
so we think at least this is the very
clear view in spain
we better make sure that we manage this
rapture
that brexit represents by building a new
trade agreement
that helps us manage the post brexit
the costs will be high if we do not have
an agreement
we don't want to see that sure but but
as things stand
and please feel free to correct me if
i'm wrong but as things stand what the
united what the european union is
proposing
it's a set of circumstances in which the
eu could unilaterally decide
whether or not we had diverged and
install
tariffs by themselves just drop them
straight in
you can understand again why that is
unacceptable to so many people here in
the united kingdom
why not some joint assessment euk
why not an independent arbitration
process that's not what the european
union is asking for that's why boris
johnson is saying no
no i don't think this is a fair
representation of the situation the
situation is such and this is why the
relationship
uh between the uk and the european union
is so unique
we want to make sure both sides by the
way that we will not be
unfairly competing with each other that
we will not be unfairly competing
by dumping our products on each other's
markets
by lowering labor standards on each
other
by lowering uh fiscal measures by
lowering environmental standards that's
what's at the heart of it so let's agree
that we are not going to do that and of
course let's find a mechanism
to see whether or not this is happening
and how to treat it
this is very unique this is why i don't
think comparisons with canada with japan
and korea
with whom uh the european union has a
limited trade relationship
matter what matters here is to agree
that we are not going to be
unfairly competing with each other uh on
uh on on on such a close relationship
that we have
it's pretty much like what canada mexico
and the us
it looks more like what canada has done
with the us and mexico
than what the canada has done with the
eu
understanding that the relationship
obviously is different when you've got
an extra neighbor i wonder then
minister what effect do you think the
news that the united kingdom will be
placing royal navy ships in and around
its waters to protect
uh its fish i wonder what effect that
might have on on the negotiations
whether it brings us closer to or
further away
from a trade deal
i just think this is all uh for the
gallery i don't think this
uh is um i don't think that's a serious
i don't think that
is by the way i don't think this is
needed
but in the meantime i think what would
be
more responsible is to sit down and to
agree what kind of
relationship does the uk want with the
european union on fishing again
understanding that on this like on the
rest
there are things for the uk to win
things for the uk for the european union
to win we just have to find
this middle point but you know saying
that you're gonna send your
uh your navy to your waters fine i mean
fine
i i don't think this is the point today
um
let's chat for a moment uh scandalous
about about ratification and
and just how long these discussions uh
might go on i mean in your mind is there
a possibility
for the eu and uk to remain at the
negotiating table you're all the way up
to the 31st of december
i mean i can think in the past of a
number of occasions on which
the european union has implemented a
treaty before ratification
well it's going to be very difficult
because the the date of the first of
january was set by the uk
it wasn't said by the european union the
uk said that
it wanted to have an agreement uh
uh by the first of january and if there
wasn't an agreement then it would just
leave the
european union without an agreement so
in a way that ball is
on the uk court and one last question
minister whilst we have you um i wonder
what effect
no deal would have on the border with
gibraltar
yeah this is something that worries us
because
because the gibraltarian citizens are
friends of spain
because we know that we disagree on a
major issue
which is sovereignty there is a
disagreement between the uk and spain
on sovereignty over gibralta this is not
going to change
but my sense is that our duty is to find
a deal
that would help us build this area of
shared prosperity
around gibraltar
caring for our citizens caring
for our workers caring for our
enterprises this is why
spain has shown a
big interest and we've worked very hard
to reach an agreement with the uk
as regards uh mobility uh in
in and around the area of gibraltar out
of respect for our citizens because what
we know
that come first of january without an
agreement
the border the external border of the
european union will be into broader
and we want to avoid that so this is why
spain has put every energy into this
into this agreement we hope we can still
reach it
because we know what it will mean uh for
citizens uh
in gibraltar and in spain and because we
care about them
we want to make sure this doesn't happen
well we're going to find out what's
going to happen very very soon indeed
aren't we at minister lovely to have you
on the program this morning despite
our technical problems very merry
christmas when it comes
thank you thank you very much